the provocative transatlantic trade deal
divides opinion big discussion center
around private arbitration court and the
infamous isds a majority of MPs want a
system where the court is public via the
also gleefully huge stone I know it is
often Mulholland ago she she believes
some is simply calling for tea tip to be
dropped they say it could actually lower
standards for public health agriculture
chemical products and public procurement
HTTP um cavalo de traje de la mort in
action allie no I pensee amo que por
terra nova dis occupation a porter
'sorry risky Perla salute alimentary
mean vogliamo kcco referendum salty tipo
/ casita given a boat are the [ __ ] at
the plenary in strands burger majority
of any Peas officially back the treaty
for them without tea tip the EU stands
to lose out on business and jobs what
will happen to European standards as
China Rises if we are not part of the
global decision-making process what will
happen to the 31 million jobs they
depend directly on export any piece of
clearly signaled red lines for the
Commission in charge of negotiating the
details with the United States Emmy peas
will next be called upon to simply vote
yes oh no it's the final treaty with no
possibility of amending it